I think this is a new frontier I think
historically we have been crossing
multiple frontiers coming out of Africa
was a big leap
you know flying was a big leap going
around the world was a big leap of
course if the first man in space Yuri
Gagarin I was named after him that was
an enormous development 55 years ago
today 55 years ago today and I think
every generation needs to have this leap
ahead of them I think going to the Stars
was dream dreamed of for so long by so
many that it is really incredible that
we can announce this project today
in the 21st century based on the
developments that happen in technology
just in the last 15 years Yuri what do
you hope to find with this project
extraterrestrial life planets that
humans could inhabit at some point in
the distant future well we will know
much more about the planets in the
nearby systems stellar systems before we
launched so I don't think we're gonna
fly blind but at the same time we might
discover something unexpected so it's
unlikely that there is an intelligent
civilization in the near vicinity of the
Sun but it is likely that there is a
planet in the habitable zone and of
course that would be amazing
to fly by one of those planets and send
images back to the vector our planet
images images those are some expensive
pictures well it's it's expensive but
also exciting
I think someone might just pay a lot for
that one picture even if the technology
works as envisioned it's going to take a
generation before this project even gets
off the ground it's going to take 20
years for these miniature spacecraft to
get to Alpha Centauri and then years
more before those images are beamed back
to earth for years will you be here to
see it well that I don't know some of
the other developments in the area of
Life Sciences might make it easier to
see that happening but but I think the
most important thing is that we push
this thing forward and if need be we can
pass this baton to the next generation
so that they will rehab the results of
it but I think we don't remember that as
much but the the cathedrals were built
by many generations and and I think that
this is the kind of project that will
take a lot of efforts we have a lot of
technical challenges but the challenges
are not insurmountable and there is no
there's no scientific challenges anymore
what do you say Yuri to people who
listen to what you're saying to me who
look at the presentation you've made
today and maybe even give it a little
bit of thought and say is he kind of
crazy cuz this is pretty out there what
do you say to those people well I was
very skeptical myself even even a year
ago you know my background background is
science and I was the first to try to
punch a lot of holes
in this project we had a small team of
scientists and engineers working on this
but
but there's real incredible that only
now in 2015 or 16 we can have we can
announce this if we would be sitting
here in this chairs 10-15 years ago it
would have seemed crazy that would have
seen it would it would have been
irresponsible to me to make this
announcement and to put 100 million
dollars behind I think that now we can
we can actually make this first step and
do the feasibility study which will
hopefully give us the blueprint for the
next steps forward a year ago you were
trying to in your words punch holes into
this idea how did you get involved was
this something you wanted to do did
somebody approach you well I had this
childhood dream like many other boys
especially the ones called URIs to do to
do something and to make a contribution
to this project and and I think I'm very
fortunate that I can now devote some of
the resources so this isn't an
investment can it make money should it
even make money this is a non-profit
initiative and by the way I'm very happy
to and to announce that Mark Zuckerberg
have joined the board of this foundation
alongside Stephen Hawking and his
support was was really incredibly
important and his endorsement so so I
think that as we will pass this most
risky phase of this project when the
hundred million will be spent on
research and development I think at that
point we would be hopefully able to come
out and say that yes indeed this project
can be done in certain time frame but we
would truly believe now that it is time
to to launch this project and to make
sure that we explore the real
possibility of interstellar travel is he
contributing some of that hundred
million dollars or is he contributing is
any financial contribution he's making
over and above the 100 million not at
this point but I think he is his moral
support and endorsement
is is very important who else might you
get out money project might require much
more funding in the future
well clearly the total cost is has got
to be in the billions of dollars yes
that's correct
so you where do you raise that kind of
money NASA is tapped out the total cost
is comparable to the largest science
project that will have funded so far and
I think the closest example might be the
Large Hadron Collider engines are alive
the CERN and I think it should be a
similar collaborative effort that brings
together people from around the world
will happen can you bring together just
Western countries and organizations or
do you think you can being Russian can
you get the Russians involved can you
get the Chinese involved this project
cannot be done by one country it has to
be global as almost by definition it
represents all of us if we launch
something so far so fast as fast moving
we need to create some sort of consensus
on our planet that this is the right
thing to do there are also policy issues
that we we need to pay attention to here
so it's a combination of technology and
policy that we would need to solve in
the next 20-30 years you need to find
donors of significant means like
yourself and Mark Zuckerberg have you
been successful yet for this project yes
well this project is I'm finding myself
for the time being but again but to
realize the ambition the next phase of
the project would require there's no
funding and again as I said it will have
to be a global effort
as global as some of the major
scientific efforts we have done in the
last few years now this isn't your first
effort in space
you're already funding radio telescopes
and you invested in SpaceX as well right
yes I've I've made the investment in
SpaceX a few a few years ago but this
project is following the project that
was announced also Stephen Hawking a
year ago to look for intelligent life in
the universe let me ask you this
question URI you're doing this this is a
philanthropic effort but Richard Branson
and Jeff Bezos want to take tourists
into space
Elon Musk who is behind SpaceX also
wants to colonize Mars is it right in
your mind that space is kind of becoming
a playground for billionaires well I
honestly believe from the historic
perspective it's not gonna matter
because nobody remembers right now who
funded Columbus expedition was it the
government funding it was it a
combination of private donors was it a
public funding of sorts at the time what
we do remember is the result that is so
I think all those details and nuances on
who is funding what at this point will
not matter in the next few hundred a
thousand years URI you're you know you
made your fortune as an investor people
know you for investing in Facebook for
Twitter for example you're out of those
positions you've been selling down your
position in Alibaba and in jvcom is this
how your redeploying your capital or are
you redeploying it as an investor in
other ways well obviously my day job is
DSD this is my Xavier this is
important for me to say so 80% of my
time I'm spending on investments and 20%
of my time is dedicated to projects like
this so that's pretty much how capital
is allocated now so let's talk about the
day job for just a moment the 80% of
your time that you're dedicating towards
DST what interests you right now
what are you investing in because I can
see that you're captivated by ideas of
tremendous promise so this is what
you're doing is a hobby for example but
how about in the real world well in the
real world I think that the
technological revolution is unstoppable
I think innovation has been happening
for so long that we don't have any
reason to believe that it's gonna stop
so essentially what we do is invest in
innovation and every generation brings
their contribution to innovation and if
history is of any lesson every
generation is building their own
companies you know like Facebook like
Alibaba
like Spotify you would believe that
innovation will be dominated by big
companies big mature old companies and
and the route the answer is no every
generation is building their own
companies so innovation may be
unstoppable but you have to make some
careful and one would hope intelligent
choices about whom to invest with and
what technology so what appeals to you
right now well we continue to believe
that Internet and mobile innovation is
the space we should stay in I was very
fortunate to
to be in Korea when there was this
alphago match between a deep mind and
Google and a human being and I was
absolutely fascinated by just observing
very closely how this competition was
taking place and my biggest my biggest
eye opening experience was that the
humans could build this machine they
they really did not know why the machine
is making certain moves so here's
another big trend for you artificial
intelligence and this is something that
we we should be investing in four years
ago you told me that you would continue
to be invested with the founders of the
companies in which you held stakes so
long as they continue to push the
envelope yet you're out of facebook do
you have any regrets about that
well this is really how private equity
business works
you have to recycle again yes the our
funds have certain lifetime and we have
to return capital to invest if you could
be would you still be invested in
Facebook yes it would be yeah how about
Twitter I you know we would do evaluate
projects and companies sort of regularly
i as we are out of some of the positions
I don't follow them very closely right
you know the reason I asked that
question though it's because Facebook
right has a billion in you know 1.6
billion users and people are questioning
whether a company like Twitter is still
relevant I think Twitter is relevant I
think Twitter is is a global project if
you try to if you try to list all
projects all Internet companies with
global audience there will be probably
less than 10 and Twitter is one of them
so I think Twitter
has its followers and it's an enormous
ly important company as a way to
disseminate information like we have
been using Twitter today to make this
announcement so I think Twitter will
continue to be very important company
several of your most recent investments
are in China I mentioned JD comm their
Xiaomi and several others and you've
also been prospecting and investing in
India would you ever consider relocating
there to be closer to what you're doing
to India or to charge of China yes well
I have been traveling in the last few
years about 200 days a year and I have
been visiting and I am still visiting
China a few times a year as well as
India
40 percent of our capital was invested
in China 40 percent in u.s. and 20
percent in India and Europe and that's
pretty much how I spend my time I'm
trying to so 40 percent of the capital
deployed yes but some of that capital is
has appreciated yes at a faster rate in
China Xiaomi for example comes to mind
right a lot of people spend far too much
of their time wondering when uber is
going to go public should they instead
be wondering when Xiaomi is going to go
public I don't know this is always a
founders decision I think what is really
important is to have multiple financing
sources available so when we started to
invest six years ago in so-called late
stage internet that was something that
was not very popular I think right now
there is this whole space and there are
many funds who participate in funding
companies at late-stage which creates an
alternative for them to go public so I
think as long as all those alternatives
are available for the founders they will
be making this ultimate decision well as
as you know private funding has proven
to be perhaps a little bit disappointing
these fallen unicorns if you will
Iori one quick question before we wrap
the Silicon Valley
have the power to innovate of course if
you look at the last 15 years you know
the biggest companies in the world have
been created in Silicon Valley and it's
an incredible place in terms of
innovation in terms of influence in
terms of amount of capital but a special
intellectual capital so it's really the
the intellectual capital of the world as
far as I'm concerned so it's the
concentration of smart people
per-square-mile is unprecedented